ich arbeite vollzeit im büro und
versorge meine familie in jedem band
gemüse mit obst mit milch mit fleisch
und milchprodukten aus unserem garten
bzw von unseren eigenen tieren selber
und wie das funktioniert also wie mein
vollzeitjob und selbstversorgung unter
einen hut kriegt das erste in diesem
video
[Musik]
ich habe als reaktion auf mein letztes
video einige nachrichten bekommen die
ungefähr so lauteten liebe marie wenn du
den ganzen tag im garten sein und ist
dir leisten kannst nicht zu arbeiten
schön und gut aber für normale leute mit
vollzeitjob wäre das alles ja gar nicht
möglich
und da musste ich ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen schmunzeln
ich weiß dass viele leute denken dass
selbstversorgung sehr sehr sehr
aufwändig ist aber ich dachte nicht dass
ihr denkt dass ich den ganzen tag in
meinem garten bin das gegenteil nämlich
der fall ich arbeite um die 60 bis 70
stunden die woche im büro also fast
doppelt so viel wie man mit einem
normalen vollzeitjob arbeitet weil ich
eine eigene firma habe ich habe mehrere
mitarbeiter und ja falls irgendwer von
euch selbstständig ist wisst ihr
wahrscheinlich dass es manchmal schwer
ist wieder aufzuhören und da ich auch so
viel spaß an meiner arbeit habe will ich
mich darüber auch gar nicht beschweren
aber ich finde es ist ein gutes thema um
mal darüber zu sprechen wie viel arbeit
selbstversorgung den wirklich macht ich
kann nur über das sprechen was wir
machen auf dem level wie wir es machen
also obst gemüse milchprodukte und
fleisch wir bauen kein getreide an und
keine ölfrüchte aber ich finde das ist
ein spannendes thema und deswegen würde
ich euch gerne erzählen wie viel arbeit
unsere selbstversorgung denn wirklich
macht und das wirklich mal auf die woche
umrechnen und schauen wie viele stunden
da am ende so rum kommt die
selbstversorgung ist für uns wirklich
nur eine art hobby was nebenher läuft
und es ist auch keine feier so dass wir
den ganzen tag im garten verbringen
würden wir müssen auch geld verdienen um
unsere miete zu bezahlen
ich arbeite ja auch total gerne sonst
würde ich ja auch nicht den ganzen tag
im büro verbringen
aber es ist wirklich nicht so dass ich
ständig draußen wäre das sich ständig im
garten wäre auch wenn das wunderschön
wäre wirklich so dass die zeit im garten
und bei den tieren ein ausgleich ist für
die zeit im büro
und damit will ich auf keinen fall
behaupten dass selbstversorgung leicht
wäre oder dass es überhaupt keine arbeit
machen würde es ist verdammt harte
arbeit wenn ihr das letzte video nicht
gesehen habt über unsere tops und flops
im selbstversorger jahr 2019 dann schaut
euch das video gerne noch mal an da
erzähle ich euch genau was wirklich
schief gegangen ist und da werdet ihr
auch merken dass es wirklich keine rosa
blümchen welt ist in der wir leben
aber es ist auch nicht so dass uns das
den ganzen tag auf trab halten würde
außer es ist mein tier todkrank das kann
natürlich immer vorkommen dann gehe ich
da schon dreimal am tag hin und schaue
ob es dem gut geht und tue alles damit
es wieder gesund wird aber im alltag ist
wirklich nicht so dass mir den ganzen
tag über mit unserer selbstversorgung
beschäftigt werden und weil ich das
selber auch ganz spannend fand habe ich
einfach mal eine woche mitgeschrieben
und aufgeschrieben wie viel zeit denn
welche aufgaben kosten hier kommen
gerade ein paar hühner an bekannt die
mich total ablenken
naja damit wir eben mal so eine
übersicht haben uns wirklich schauen
können auf die stunde genau wie viel
arbeit selbst was irgendwann wirklich
macht so ich hoffe ihr könnt gut mit
lesen hier habe ich die ganzen aufgaben
aufgeschrieben geht die woche über hand
fallen und dann versteckt hinter dem
gewordenen zettel stehen die zeiten die
ziegen wollen also versorgt und geborgen
werden das braucht am tag ungefähr 20
minuten bilden eine ziege wir haben 3
und ja da fallen so aufgaben an die
häufig an die wollen jeden tag frisches
wasser natürlich manchmal muss man den
zaun um stecken vor allem im sommer
dafür dass frei fit dann weg stattdessen
muss man sie ab und zu umstellen
die neue beiden abfressen können und
eben das melden
das melken selbst was mich ungefähr so
fünf bis zehn minuten am tag
ja dann will die mich natürlich auch
verarbeitet werden da mache ich es so
dass sich die immer drei tage lang
sammeln und dann mit einer größeren
menge käse herstellen und joghurt und da
würde ich sagen dass ich ungefähr 20
minuten brauchte je nachdem welchem käse
ich mache manchmal sind es auch nur zehn
minuten manchmal sind es auch 30 minuten
aber im schnitt alle drei tage 20
minuten für die milchverarbeitung die
hühner füttern den stall auf und zu
machen da komme ich auf ungefähr 10
minuten am tag dann müssten wir einmal
über eine stelle aus das kostet nochmal
ungefähr eine stunde in der woche
wir backen alle zwei bis drei tage brot
das dauert ungefähr 40 minuten natürlich
buck das brot länger aber die zeit wo
beweglich was dafür tun müssen wie den
teig zu kneten oder mehl zu mahlen
da kommen wir auf 40 minuten und der
garten das wird wahrscheinlich einige
von euch erstaunen braucht ungefähr drei
stunden in der woche
das ist erstaunlich wenig das war auch
nicht immer so am anfang war das noch
deutlich mehr das waren da ungefähr 15
stunden die woche
als wir noch weniger erfahrung hatten
und als wir noch nicht nach dem system
gegärtnert haben wie wir es jetzt machen
und dann kommen wir noch mal auf
ungefähr einer stunde die woche zum
haltbarmachen der ernte also um sachen
einzukochen einzulagern zu fermentieren
damit wir eben im winter immer noch das
ganze gute sommer gemüse essen können
und wenn man das alles zusammenrechnet
dann kommen wir auf 590 minuten das sind
nicht mal zehn stunden die woche
ich finde es ganz spannend wenn ihr mal
unten in den kommentaren verratet was
ihr gedacht habt auf welche zahl das
ganze
ihr genaues laufen wird also nicht mal
zehn stunden die woche das ist wirklich
wirklich machbar
ihr könnt es euch denken die zahlen die
ich dafür den garten und fürs
haltbarmachen angesetzt habe variieren
natürlich im jahresverlauf beim garten
gar nicht so arg weil wir auch im winter
sehr viel gärtnern also unser garten
wird wirklich das ganze jahr über
genutzt aber es gibt eben diese
stoßzeiten wo ganz viel gesät und
gepflanzt werden muss und dann die
erntezeit im sommer wo auch ganz viel
haltbar gemacht wird deswegen habe ich
da jetzt zeiten angenommen die so ein
durchschnittswert darstellen über das
ganze jahr gerechnet
natürlich stehen manchmal auch größere
aktionen an wie einen stall zu bauen
oder einen garten anzulegen
das sind natürlich erst mal größere
brocken arbeit die am anfang jedes
projektes erstmal anstehen weil man
infrastrukturen schaffen muss damit das
ganze überhaupt erst möglich ist das
gehört natürlich auch dazu das heißt man
muss schon damit rechnen dass man an den
wochenenden öfters mal mit ein paar
leuten zusammen irgendwas wucht und
wieder irgendwas auf die beine stellt
aber letztendlich ist es wirklich nicht
viel zeit die uns die selbstversorgung
kostet wenn man auch berücksichtigt dass
mein freund ja auch sehr viel macht der
ist zwar bei den tieren nicht ganz so
enthusiastisch wie ich aber der backt
unser brot komplett selber und er hilft
auch ganz ganz viel im garten mit so
dass diese zehn stunden die da jetzt bei
rumgekommen sind auch nicht allein auf
meinen schultern lasten sondern mein
freund und mein sohn mittlerweile auch
ganz viele arbeiten übernehmen
natürlich dauert am anfang wenn man noch
gar keine erfahrung hat alles viel viel
länger als wenn man sein eingebucht ist
und weiß was man macht ich habe jetzt
seit ich zwölf bin ziegen also seit 13
oder 14 jahren das heißt da ja
da habe ich meine abläufe und ich weiß
genau was ich mache ich weiß so ziemlich
alles über ziegen kann ich ganz ehrlich
behaupten so dass das wirklich arbeit
spart und im garten haben wir
mittlerweile auch so viel erfahrung der
garten macht zwischen aussaat und ernte
kaum noch arbeit dass es auch etwas
worüber ich gerne noch mal in einem
separaten video sprechen möchte weil es
da einfach techniken gibt die man sich
im garten ganz ganz ganz viel arbeit
sparen können wir gießen zum beispiel
fast gar nicht und wir haben fast kein
unkraut im garten und das spart immens
viel arbeit also da würde ich gerne noch
mal ein video darüber drehen wenn euch
das interessiert dann lasst mich das
gerne unten in den kommentaren wissen
dann könnte ich nächste woche mal
erzählen wie diese drei stunden
gartenarbeit die ich da aufgeschrieben
habe oder was ich da behaupte wie die
zustande kommen und wieso das so wenig
zeit ist generell mache ich mir immer
gedanken über abläufe egal ob es bei den
tieren ist in der küche oder im garten
und überlege mir wie ich die arbeiten
möglichst effizient verrichtet gerade
wenn das so arbeiten sind wie ich jeden
tag machen muss weil das wirklich zeit
spart auf die lange sicht wenn man sich
einmal die zeit nimmt um zu überlegen
wie man sich was ein richtet damit es
dann wirklich gut und reibungslos
funktioniert im alltag ich weiß von mir
selber dass wenn ich vor einem neuen
projekt steht egal ob das jetzt
hühnerhaltung ist oder ob ich wohl
selber machen wie das ist immer im kopf
immer so riesig groß ist und dass ich
mir immer vorstellen wie viel arbeit das
wohl sein muss und wenn ich es dann
selber machen und ein bisschen reinkomme
und mehr erfahrungen sammeln dann merke
ich dass es eigentlich gar kein
hexenwerk ist so ist es bisher bei allem
was wir in der selbstversorgung
ausprobiert haben gewesen es ist
wirklich kein hexenwerk also traut euch
große träume zu haben und traut euch
raus zu gehen und einfach mal zu machen
einfach mal zu gucken natürlich will ich
nicht sagen dass ihr alles auf einmal
anfangen soll weil das ist einfach da
ist es dann garantiert dass ihr euch
überfordert aber ich finde man muss sich
schon etwas zutrauen und man muss den
mut haben einfach mal zu machen